les historiens attribuent la recette
originale de l'île flottante à auguste
escoffier le père de la cuisine
française est moderne à qui on attribue
aussi la création de nombreux desserts
mais la recette d'escoffier diffère
beaucoup de celles d'aujourd'hui
en fait une île flottante c'est vraiment
le rassemblement de trois recettes
on a d'un côté une crème anglaise d'un
autre côté un caramel et enfin d'un
autre côté une meringue légère c'est
vraiment trois recettes qu'on va
combiner ensemble pour donner l'île
flottante au restaurant l'express
montréal l'île flottante est un des
classiques depuis plus de 30 ans c'est
un incontournable évidemment des gens
viennent de loin pour pour manger cette
fameuse île flottante qui quand même
fait produits en petites quantités en
effet comme deux fois par jour non en
fait 8 à la fois ensuite pour le matin
pour le soir quand c'est fini c'est fini
donc d'où le pourquoi les gens vont là
réservé quand il contient une version
maison de l'île flottante est
relativement simple à concocter avec
quelques ingrédients de base
que ce soit au restaurant ou à la maison
certaines étapes sont identiques dans un
premier temps oui on va clarifier nos et
clarifier ça veut tout simplement dire
séparez les blancs des jaunes
c'est quand même intéressant de savoir
que de monter des blancs si on applique
les bonnes techniques sans blague c'est
facile c'est vraiment pas quelque chose
de compliqué parce que les gens nous
serviront à quelque chose me suis alors
les jours ça va être la base de notre
recette de crème anglaise il n'y a pas
de pertes dans ce dessert l'oeil pour
monter des blancs en neige ça prend
plusieurs choses d'abord on prend une
pincée de sel
ça ça va les aider à monter battus à la
mer ou avec un malaxeur on débute
lentement puis on accélère en ajoutant
le sucre
et voilà on a un beau bec d'oiseau c'est
vraiment ça qu'on recherche sur le feu
on prépare un caramel en faisant mijoter
lentement du sucre et de pourquoi mais
de l'autre simplement pour diffuser la
chaleur pour la confection de la crème
anglaise
il faut blanchir les jaunes d'oeufs on
veut faire fondre le sucre dans les
jaunes deux voiliers léger commence à
blanchir les virements
on a les yeux à linge oui on a notre
lait pour faire notre kremlin aux fins
de travail d'anvers doucement je vais
mélanger en même temps pourquoi parce
que si je mélangeais pas ça se pourrait
que la chaleur de mon les cuisses mes
yeux lorsqu on va faire notre mélange et
là on va leur montée en température
si on y va graduellement en faisant des
huit comme ça il ya des indices visuels
qui sont à mon avis plus fiable qu'un
thermomètre donc le premier d'entre eux
quand j'atteins ma température ma crème
anglaise va commencer à être beaucoup
plus illustre est beaucoup plus satiné
en surface elle va briller en plus voyez
la petite mousse convoi qui floppe le
rhin elle va presque disparaître quand
on va atteindre l'épaisseur voulu la
mousse a disparu et surtout avec mon
doigt là si je fais un très sale sans
gros con une consistance de catane
il va nous rester notre caramel à faire
et ensuite à maintenant de meringue à
l'intérieur ce que je vais faire
maintenant je vais chemise et mon moule
donc chemise et ça veut dire que je vais
enrober les côtés de caramel et une fois
qu'on a tous fini comme sont répartis et
à anvers voyez complètement
donc ce que je vais faire maintenant je
vais tout simplement basculer ma
meringue dans ma casseroles à l'express
la chef pâtissier a fleuri au bord des
chemises les moules avec de l'huile
végétale
dans les deux cas il faut s'assurer de
bien pousser la meringue au fond du
récipient et de la lys et avant de la
mettre au four il va nous rester à la
mettre dans le four 1 10 à 12 minutes
pas plus
à combien par 350 une des
caractéristiques de l'île flottante de
l'express et son dôme de caramel on voit
lors de la confection c'est vraiment le
caramel en robe lamée règne bien comme
il faut et puis avec le froid la
meringue se rétracte et puis fait en
sorte que l'on est prêt sont vraiment
qu'un dôme de karameh n'était pas posée
sur le dessous de son côté le chef rue
mieux des buts l'étape finale de sa
préparation
et voilà notre meringue qui descend tout
doucement on se coupe à la casserole on
la laisse descendre délicatement et
voilà non on fait une recette pour
combien de personnes 6 à 8 personnes ça
est ce que ces prêts alain comme ça ou
faux et c'est mieux d'attendre pour
refroidir un peu
alors habituellement ou un dessert qu'on
laisse on va pouvoir reposer au frigo
pendant 1 4 5 heures pour que vraiment
la crème anglaise le caramel tout ça
refroidisse paix que ce soit vraiment
frais en bouche c'est pas un dessert
d'iliad dans mais c'est moi j'aime la
légèreté de ce dessin
c'est plus que légèrement bon c'est cela
oui ça ça c'est hautement dit on tape un
bon petit coup sûr juste pour éclater et
puis on a su prendre un peu de tout en
même temps on voit quand même si c'est
très léger
[Musique]
danse enfants que ça à une personne ça
fait quand même pas mal
on dirait que c'est pour 2 puis
peut-être trop
[Musique]
à